hi guys this is Chloe Grace Moretz and
this is the wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
have you ever Googled
of course not a good thing to do but
yeah I have definitely Fallen victim to
the Googling
what was Chloe Grace moretz's first
movie my first movie would have been the
Amityville Horror with Ryan Reynolds and
when I was a child everyone was always
like was it so hard to act with them
because he's so hot and I was like five
and I was like what what languages does
Clover is
um what languages does i i does all the
languages like for Suspiria I had to
learn German well pieces of German and
my character was being like possessed by
a demon and so at the end she says some
really gnarly stuff we kept trying to
figure out how to say like what was
c-u-n-t in German like what would have
the same gravity and so it ended up
being like three different words that
apparently get across that that tone
Speak oh oh my God
does Chloe Grace Moretz play video games
yeah I do I love video games I love
first person shooters but I also love
like MMO RPG games so I play a lot of
Final Fantasy and getting into Destiny
are you excited for Call of Duty oh my
God I'm excited yeah I played like the
beta as much as possible they just
invited me because I decided to tweet
about it and I hadn't tweeted in a long
time so everyone including my own
publicist thought that I was uh hacked
and they're like are you okay why is she
talking about video games so much
I also do my own stunts
does Chloe Grace Moretz play cello no I
I would love to say that I could I did a
movie called if I say it was really
wonderful I got to learn to play cello
for about three and a half months which
is not long enough to learn such an
intricate instrument but I also had an
incredible double who was a beautiful
cellist they would cut my head off and I
would just be like
and then they would like put the body in
and she's like
then I'm like
yeah acting
does Chloe Grace Moretz know martial
arts I do know martial arts I did a
movie called Kick-Ass when I was 11. and
I got to work with Brad Allen who is
sadly passed away now from that movie
Forward I tried to stay with it for most
of my life and on the peripheral I had
the opportunity to get back into it but
now I'm also doing Judo which is really
really fun and exciting so I'm trying to
integrate different forms of martial
arts besides my main one which is Muay
Thai does Chloe Grace Moretz sing I do
sing I don't do it professionally but I
really love singing and actually during
the pandemic I taught myself to play the
guitar does Chloe Grace Moretz have a
tattoo I do I have a lot of tattoos and
they're all pretty hidden and the only
reason I hide like I have them hidden is
because as an actor you have to spend a
lot of time in hair and makeup if you
have tattoos and as a child actor I saw
all these adults be like don't ever get
tattoos because you're gonna have to
come in at 3am and they're gonna have to
cover your tattoos from like 3 to 6 a.m
and then then you'll start regular hair
and makeup I got one on vacation once
there is someone at the at the hotel we
were staying out there like we do
tattoos we can totally come to your room
uh a horrible idea all I was gonna get
was three dots and it was first of all
the most painful tattoo I've literally
ever had in my life I was about to cry
and me and my stylist who I've known
since I was 11. we did it at the same
time and she and I are both like at
least we did this together
wow that really floated
is Chloe Grace Moretz nice no oh she
I have to deal with her every day I
think she's nice and I don't I don't
know I guess we're gonna have to like
read the room after this you know and
maybe take a tally okay is Chloe Grace
Moretz British no but funny enough I did
fool Martin Scorsese into thinking that
I was I had to auditioned for a movie
called Hugo cabre and he was only going
to hire British girl and I was like yeah
I can do that so I went into the
audition and I fully pretended to be
from England and that my parents wore
horse breeders and that we lived in the
Cotswolds I had a whole whole big lie a
huge lie and then I booked the part and
it was like a month into production that
he was like wait are you just doing an
American accent and I was like no I'm
like American like my accent is Southern
naturally if I don't iron it out I guess
maybe I am British so
depends if I believe my own lie is Chloe
Grace Moretz real no she is an NPC I am
a lot of the times uh piloted by AI um
and there's like a series of little
humans that kind of like do different
shifts inside me and uh allow me to live
I don't know I think maybe I'm real are
any of us real it's a big question
does Chloe Grace Moretz have social
media I do I have Twitter I have
Instagram I watch Twitch a lot I don't
actually like stream on Twitch but I
think I might and I have Tick Tock I
really don't post on Tick Tock but I
like it and I like all the weird beauty
hacks and I try them all I didn't try
the banana one did you guys see that one
where you take a banana to do eyeliner
maybe I should have tried it maybe
that's the moral of the story how old
was Chloe Grace Moretz in Kick-Ass 10
when I booked it and then I trained for
six months and then I filmed it just as
I turned 11 and can Chloe Grace Moretz
yeah didn't we just answer that one yeah
yeah we did right now I'm a little raspy
so I don't know what I'd sound like clay
Grace Moretz God I can't imagine this is
just gonna be it's just my name and then
something Chloe Grace Moretz cars I love
cars I have a 110 Defender and I have a
rooftop tint on it and I take it camping
I love uh over landing and so I like to
Kit out my car with a bunch of like
Doomsday gear I bet like if like the end
of the world was near you'd probably
want to come to my house just so we
could take my car but no I really love
cars and I actually really really want
to get into car restoration I like
motorized things Chloe Grace morads
brown hair I got blonde hair but I did
go Brown for a couple times I wore brown
wig and if I stay and then I dyed my
hair brown for The Equalizer and it was
fun I've been blonde for so long people
do get a little like surprised if I
change something you know I think is why
everyone that's why they also Google
whether or not I've had plastic surgery
but I'm just me I'm a real girl
's restaurant I love eating I love a
restaurant I love to cook I like food I
don't have a restaurant though if that's
what they're getting at here there ain't
no Chloe Grace Moretz restaurant but who
knows you know Chloe Grace morad's if I
say oh yeah this is the one that I was
talking about earlier RJ Cutler directed
it and it was based on a really
wonderful book yeah it was like my first
like young adult uh romance film and it
was really sweet and I got to work with
Jamie Blackley and he was such a nice
guy and it was also a really sad story
like everyone dies in it spoiler alert
is like probably one of my favorite
movies I've been a part of it's a really
really sweet one Chloe Grace Moretz
that's funny out of context that's so
weird but anyone that really like
personally knows me will get it I wash
my face with olive oil every night it's
pretty much the only cleanser that I use
I used to have cystic acne for a really
long time
because of Carrie I had the blood on me
every day and I got a bacterial
infection and the thing that really
resolved my issues and cleared my skin
up was olive oil and then my toner is
apple cider vinegar so I like to call
myself a salad dressing you know like
Newman's Own it's going to be Chloe's
own move over Paul Newman
I feel like the three names sometimes is
egregious I'm gonna be honest I feel
like my mom went a little too far they
like have making people type all that in
is rude technically my like birth
certificate would have the umlo right
over my little e and my mom hates it if
I don't sign it with my little dots
She'll always like I gave you those
beautiful thoughts why don't you use
them okay anyway Chloe Grace Moretz Hugo
this is a movie I did with Martin
Scorsese
I was 13 years old I want to say when we
first showed up myself in Asa
Butterfield we were both children and
Marty is a cinephile like through and
through 100 and he had someone send to
both of our houses a huge cardboard box
and inside the box it was probably 25 or
so films and they were all uh very
particular films each of our boxes were
different and he was like don't even
think of showing up to set and until you
watch all of these so we watched every
single film and then every day we would
go to set he would bring them up in
different ways and we would discuss them
and he really was uh a film history
class you know he is just such a
cinephile and that movie was so much so
his Ode to cinema and his love of
cinnamon that's just like you know such
an integral part of my life being on
that satin it really shaped me Chloe
Grace Moretz Marvel I have never been in
Marvel before I have like chatted with
them about certain roles at different
times I would love the idea to be in one
you know I think it'd be fun to to do DC
or Marvel I think they're both really
cool but I kind of want to play a
villain I think it'd be kind of fun to
be a little bit of a baddie and not so
much like a goody goody kind of
character Chloe Grace Moretz latest
movie my latest movie actually that'll
be coming out next year will be this
Animation Show movie I did called nimona
it is made by Big Sky and they're really
really incredible and we're doing it
with um Riz Ahmed who I really love and
being able to work with him has been so
fun outside of that I am in a TV show
right now on Prime video called the
peripheral which I'm really really proud
of and it's my very first time doing
television is really it's really
wonderful and exciting
thank you guys so much for watching that
was my wired autocomplete interview and
thank you for Googling me
[Music]